IN THIS CASE HOPEFULLY WE WILL
END WE WILL GET THOSE ANSWERS
AND LEARN FROM IT.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
GREAT INSIGHTS AS ALWAYS.
THERE'S ANOTHER ASPECT OF THIS
STORY WE ARE GOING TO GET TO
TONIGHT.
EARLIER TODAY, A "TIME" MAGAZINE
HEADLINE BLARED ACCUSED PARKLAND
SHOOTER NICHOLAS CRUZ WAS A
MEMBER OF A WHITE SUPREMACIST
GROUP.
MANY OTHERS, BIG NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS RAN STORIES THAT
THIS WAS CONFIRMED BY THE LEADER
OF THIS WHITE NATIONALIST GROUP.
EXCEPT NOW, POLICE ARE SAYING
THERE ARE NO APPARENT TIES
BETWEEN A WHITE NATIONALIST
MILITIA AND THE SHOOTERS.
TEN MEMBERS AND RUN BY A
COMPLETE NUT BAG, HE IS A TOTAL
WHACK JOB.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS THIS
ANOTHER RUSH TO JUDGMENT IS
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO.
I SAW THIS POP UP ON MY PHONE.
MY DETECTOR WENT UP.
>> THE MEDIA ALWAYS GETS AHEAD
OF ITS SKIS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
GET THEIR FIRST THEY WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF THE STORY.
THEY WANT TO ASSIGN A POLITICAL
MOTIVE AND WE'VE SEEN THIS AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
THIS WHITE SUPREMACIST GUY WHO
IS THE HEAD OF THE AUTO MILITIA
GROUP HE CLAIMED THIS KID
TRAINED WITH HIM IN TALLAHASSEE.
TURNED OUT HE WAS WRONG BUT HE
TOLD THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
THIS STORY AND IT SPREAD LIKE
WILDFIRE.
EVEN THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER AND OTHERS SAID THIS
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
WE CAN'T CONFIRM THIS.
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT SAYS THERE
SEEMS TO BE A CONNECTION.
>> Laura: WHY WOULD YOU RELY
ON THIS FREAK FROM THIS WHITE
NATIONALIST FOR INFORMATION?
>> IT'S A HOT HEADLINE.
>> Laura: TELL ME ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH GABBY GIFFORDS.
>> THEY WERE BLANK BLAMING
>> THEY WERE BLANK BLAMINS
>> THEY WERE BLANK BLAMINR
>> THEY WERE BLANK BLAMINH
PALIN'S-YEAR-OLD WEBSITE, THERE
IS A ON GABBY GIFFORDS THIS MUST
BE THE REASON THE SHOOTER GOT
INVOLVED.
>> Laura: THE COUNTY SHERIFF
SAID JARED LAUTNER TARGETED THE
TEA PARTY IN HIS COMMENTS, HE
SAID THE TEA PARTY CREATES THIS
ATMOSPHERE.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRIGGERED.
THEY TRIGGERED THE SKY, LIKE THE
TEA PARTY IS TO BLAME.
HE SAID HE LISTENED TO TALK
RADIO AT SOME POINT.
>> WITH THE TIMES SQUARE BOMBER
IN 2010, THE GUY MAY HAVE SET UP
THIS BOMB BECAUSE HE WAS UPSET
WITH THE HEALTH CARE PLAN.
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL OF THESE
POLITICAL MOTIVES, WE UNDERCUT
REAL INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S DISCOVERIES
AND WE MISS THE HUMAN DIMENSION.
WHAT MIGHT BE MOTIVATING THESE
KIDS TO ENACT HORRIBLE VIOLENCE
ON THEIR PEERS AND DISCOVERING
THE NEXT KID.
YOU HIT IT, I THINK IT'S RIGHT
ON.
>> Laura: THE RUSH TO
POLITICIZE ALWAYS SEEMS TO GO IN
ONE DIRECTION.
MEANWHILE WE WILL TALK TO STEVE
SCULLY'S COMING UP.
A BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTER SHOT
HIM BUT WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT THAT
ANYMORE.
>> STRANGE HOW THEY DEEP-SIXED